it's not death that I fear not anymore
my spirit was broken just by seeing that
aura
if court I would have had no way to
resist that is what this aura is telling
me this is as far as I can go hello and
welcome to Honda into 101 series breaks
down everyone and everything in the
Hunter hunter world and today we are
going to be inspecting the bespectacled
gentleman hunter nava nava is a young
hunter typically seen in a schmack black
suit and pale blue tie it was first
introduced in the series during the
Chimera ant arc at first glance Nava
peers to sport a cold and distant
demeanor with a sense of overwhelming
confidence of borders on arrogance
however much of this is a facade which
serves to mask a deeply caring and
cautious individual now unfortunately
disgustingly little is known about knobs
background and when I say little I mean
nothing he appears in the series as a
highly experienced hunter and despite
the fact that he does not have any star
rating from the hunter Association he
was one of the two individuals trusted
by chairman Metro to accompany him to
the neo green life autonomous region to
conduct the extermination of the Chimera
and threat furthermore Nava is also
skilled enough to have his own
apprentice a woman by the name of palm
Siberia who also happens to be entirely
infatuated with him and despite nerves
general public demeanor the two of them
do share a strong bond and he does
genuinely care for pom having shown to
be exceptionally worried about her
safety during the extermination mission
now also seems to be very very aware of
Palms feelings towards him and he has
used this knowledge to manipulate and
calm her down on at least one occasion
and knobs caring side would pop out
briefly once more when he entered NGO
encountering Kilwa and an unconscious
gone for the first time after the two
were taunted by moral no I've told him
to go easy on the boys showing a hint of
sympathy for this situation although a
severe lack of empathy because he
immediately dismissed killer was
concerns of being able to complete their
mission
he further told kilowatt that people
tend to become fearful and irrational
when facing the unknown let's all just
take a moment to file that statement
away in memory for future reference but
for now nerves role in the extermination
quest was absolutely integral due to his
particular nen abilities north is a
Kandra meaning that he can create
physical constructs from his aura and
with this in mind North has developed
quite an impressive heart to known as
hide and seek which allows nerves contre
rooms that exist within a pocket
dimension and then in reality he can
craft portal to these rooms by drawing
various symbols in a circle in total the
space north can create has been said to
equate to a four level mansion
containing twenty-one
separate rooms of various sizes and very
importantly each room is completely
separate from the others so if you were
a guest in novice and minimalist mansion
in order to access one room from another
you would have to step out of the pocket
dimension and re-enter it from the
appropriate connecting portal however
this does not apply to know if who
happens to possess a very handy master
key which is able to connect any room to
any previously established portal
wherever in the world it just so happens
to be this heart so has been hailed as
an extraordinary ability amongst
prominent hunters and even members of
the zodiac making novel leader in the
field of storage and transportation and
the idea that north can conjure and
maintain a structure of this scale
within a pocket dimension should also be
highlighted because we've encountered
similar powers over the course of the
series such as chi Chi's taghut su they
come with strict conditions and
limitations so the fact that nob is able
to create and sustain the structure
seemingly indefinitely says vast amounts
about his skill as an end user of course
it doesn't end there either because
Navon also use this form of aura
offensively as well via the heart to
screen whereby he conjures a portal
between his hands wraps it around his
opponent and OnCommand the bottle then
closes sending whatever unfortunate
parts were caught in it into the pocket
dimension which is just terrifying so
equipped with hide and seek knobs
primary mission during the extermination
was to secure entry into the ant king's
palace by scattering various
strategically placed portals in and
around the premises sounds like a simple
enough task however this would end up
becoming the greatest obstacle North had
ever encountered in his life start with
some perspective to pure strength of the
chimera ants in question was entirely
off the scale compared to anything we
had seen in the series at that point a
single member of the Royal Guard was
able to easily slaughter an incredibly
powerful hunter in the form of kite and
as for king mera well he remains the
strongest living being we have ever seen
in this world and you know all of a
sudden of doesn't look so great in
comparison and it was his job to
infiltrate their stronghold alone a task
in which fear consumed more and more of
nerve the closer he got to the building
and this fear would later overwhelm him
when he encountered the N of Shia poof
one of the King's Royal Guard now to be
clear this was not Shia proofs bren
which is a hostile expression of aura
that can result in the blood loss
phenomenon this was a simple end an
extension of aura performed by the user
to keep a keen awareness of their
immediate surroundings
however this n was potent and sinister
enough to send nerve into a state of
pure terror not so much because he
feared death but because he feared the
torture that he may be subject to as
well as his inability to endure it and
thus causing the entire operation to
fail and Sonos swiftly retreated and
once
was out of range he collapsed both
mentally and physically suffering a
breakdown that would lead to his hair
turning completely white and his
subsequent withdrawal from the
extermination team and in fact this
event went on to completely reshape
Noel's character from cold and confident
to a more warm and empathetic persona
furthermore it also led him to
developing great respect for gon and
killua the two young boys that he had
previously taken pity on from their
first encounter where they were broken
and defeated and North was now
experiencing the entirely opposite
situation becoming fearful and
irrational due to the unknown the exact
same thing that he accused killer of
being subject to meanwhile gone and kill
watched confidently into the
extermination mission determined to
succeed warned of was rendered helpless
that thought went on to spark a huge
sense of guilt within or for not being
able to participate and despite his
trauma he did summon the courage to step
into the palace saving the life of shoot
in the process
although nerves trauma was still such
that it was reflected in the almost
complete loss of his hair following the
death of Mara web and the success of the
mission Nava filled with emotions of
complex guilt respect and responsibility
became one of the chief architects who
ensured Gunn's recovery from the
incident at all costs and I literally
mean all costs as he even offered to pay
for the rebuilding of an entire Hospital
should it come to that
and after gone successful recovery nob
is one of several key figures who
accompanies him to the election of the
14th hunter chairman and currently North
has made tremendous steps towards his
mental recovery and has even agreed to
partially accompany the expedition to
the Dark Continent although he refuses
to set foot on the continent itself
which was the point of origin of the
Chimera Hance showing that Nova still
retains a heavy layer of trauma from
which he may never recover some more fun
facts about nob North has a particular
penchant for gambling which was shown
when he wages 1 million jeni against
morale and furthermore stating that he
has an appetite for long shots
thankfully he is a good spot though and
he did end up paying morale after losing
the bet nerves name is entirely possibly
based on the word nob due to his ability
that one might say allows him to create
doors into his pocket dimension and
finally a truly useless fact when
entering NGO a nation that bans any form
of modern technology or materials know
of quite clearly broke the rules simply
by wearing his glasses that pretty much
does it for naught if you enjoyed this
video on the content this channel
produced in general then please do
consider donating to the new world
review patreon because the support of
all the amazing people is what continues
to make this channel possible and if
patreon isn't quite your style then
please do
video a like share or subscribe because
it also helps block this channel an
incredible amount and if you'd like to
join the fun at any time then please do
head over to my discord server where a
wide array of shenanigan retakes place
on a daily basis and finally please do
comment with who what or where you'd
like to see featured in the next Hunter
hunter 101
you